we do have major breaking news president
donald trump has announced that he has
tested
positive for coronavirus and there are
so many layers to discuss uh i i hope to
discuss
all of them let's go through it in
sequence first what has been alleged
what do we believe that we know about
the situation well
uh late last night early this morning
close to 1am eastern time donald trump
tweeted
today first lady of the united states
and i meaning
melania tested positive for covet 19. we
will begin our quarantine and recovery
process
immediately we will get through this
together
news of this came after it was announced
that a close
uh staffer to donald trump hope hicks
had tested positive now
already just based on the facts with no
speculation
we know that irresponsible behavior took
place here
we've since learned that there was
actually a concern about hope hicks
early on thursday and that donald trump
knowing he had been exposed still went
to a fundraiser did not wear a mask and
we don't know how many more people were
exposed
as a result of donald trump's behavior
after being in contact with hope hicks
not surprising he's not taking it
seriously from the beginning
second a ton of people don't believe
this and
i am not uh asserting any conspiracy
but when i woke up this morning the
number of people who had emailed me
saying
this is a ruse to get out of the debates
trump doesn't really have coronavirus
this is a staged plan to in 10 days or
12 days for trump to come out and say i
beat it i told you it's no big deal
to make him seem strong to his followers
maybe to say i beat it with hydroxy or i
beat it with redesvir we have such great
trees
treatments or plasma or plasma or
whatever right
the counter to that would be yeah i mean
i get it trump lies all the time and he
might be lying about everything
including this
wouldn't just getting it make him look
weak to some of his supporters it seems
like an
you know potentially risky gambit to lie
about having it to then lie about
beating it
but there is widespread uh concern about
this
the the the sort of uh less wacky
idea that a lot of people are emailing
me about
is well isn't it possible that this is
an escape pod for donald trump
because he sees the writing on the wall
after that first debate
the odds of biden winning have gone up
the odds of biden winning
of of trump winning have gone down and
donald trump
we knew all along that if he lost he was
going to say i got screwed by
coronavirus otherwise
i would have won everything was great
best economy black people were working
all the stuff he says hispanic low
unemployment
all of this stuff uh that now seeing the
writing on the wall
he is potentially using this to simply
get out
and or even to throw the election he
doesn't necessarily
i mean if he were to get very sick he
wouldn't even necessarily have to say
i'm no longer running but you would
imagine
that there are some people who would say
i can't vote for a guy who's so sick we
need a healthy president
i i just i understand why people are
suspicious because this is an
administration
that has lied constantly about
everything
but as of right now um at at least
plausibly donald trump has coronavirus
is experiencing mild
cold like symptoms and um
uh is quarantining all future
uh immediately future events have been
canceled of course the second debate is
scheduled for about 12 days from today
it's
not this coming thursday in other words
not six days from today
but the following thursday i guess that
makes that 13 days from today
it would be very borderline given
how long one can remain infectious it
would be very borderline to be able to
be at an in-person debate
13 days from today if you just tested
positive yesterday so no announcement
has been made as of this moment
it's something we're going to be
following it's something that that we
are
uh going to be tracking here uh
the the sort of next layer to this is
you know
a lot of the a lot of the feelings
that have been bottled up for months uh
or not bottled up
but but sort of simmering there about
donald trump not taking this seriously
and so on they are coming out and there
are a lot of people who are saying what
i think are sort of horrible things
about they hope trump dies i'm getting
tweets and messages
i hope trump gets a really serious case
i hope he does i i think that
that happens to be both morally wrong
uh and also strategically wrong let me
take it one by one
first the moral part i don't wish death
or disease on anyone even bad people
i don't really believe in karma but it
just feels wrong to me
to hope for things like that now i
understand
trump has not taken the 211 212
000 american coronavirus deaths
seriously so why should we care about
one
we're not like them okay we're better
than them
we're not going to stoop to their level
so
donald trump deserves to lose and this
gets to the practical trump deserves to
lose and he deserves to be voted out
via a massive repudiation by the
american people
not by getting sick okay so i
i maintain uh and listen this is not the
hill i'm going to die on i understand
why some people are reacting in these
ways screw trump and all
i get it but uh uh if for for me
i would take no not only do i not take
pleasure in people getting sick and
dying
fundamentally that seems that that is
antithetical to my beliefs
i wouldn't take pleasure in removing
trump because he gets sick or dies
i want him repudiated by the vote
plain and simple period uh full stop now
by the way uh just as a funny funny or
ironic or coincidental personal story uh
i've been having some uh
what i think are sort of allergic
symptoms lately
and my doctor said listen before we test
for allergies
because coronavirus is so weird get
yourself a coronavirus test so i
actually went yesterday after filming
the show and i got one and it really
wasn't too bad
uh they're using a much thinner swab now
and
you know whatever when i woke up this
morning anticipating
my coronavirus test results i saw trump
had tested positive for coronavirus and
again
it trump's test and my test are
completely unrelated
but for some reason i had this vision of
announcing both
that trump had tested positive and that
i had tested positive i tested negative
uh got my results this morning within
minutes of hearing about donald trump's
positive test
completely unrelated but just a uh a
timing
issue has me announcing that today
hopefully my test was an accurate
negative
uh we wouldn't want a a false negative
so we're going to continue following
this
no trump events scheduled for the
foreseeable future as a result of this
donald trump will be quarantining he has
coronavirus melania trump has
coronavirus
hope hicks has coronavirus and i would
not be surprised to see others test
positive
in the days to come